this is a Fox News Alert there is a ton
of new information coming out in the Las
Vegas shooting investigation the
months-long one Charlie Mann is a
documentary filmmakers investing in the
case he joins us but we'll start with
former Secret Service agent Dan bungee
know who was talking in sources tonight
Dan what have you learned
you know Tucker there's two big
outstanding questions right now right
the first is obviously motive why does a
guy like this engage in the one of the
largest mass murders in American history
you know lo the motive is still unclear
and I can't absolutely confirm anything
I believe that there's a high
probability in the end you're gonna see
something that looks like some form of
radicalization now what that
radicalization was it's always
associated with the course Islamic
terror given the threat environment that
may not be in it may be some kind of
political motivation as well but motive
is obviously outstanding and one more
quick point on this Tucker um I don't
think the target selection here was
random the fact that it was a country
music concert the fact that it was Las
Vegas I don't think this was random and
I think may in fact when this all comes
out in the wash I'll be effective it's
one other quick thing on this the second
point was he alone now it's pretty
obvious he was the lone gunman in this
case through based on all the evidence
we have but that's not what I'm asking
was he alone or did he have some kind of
support structure in place again I think
when a lot of this gets fleshed out and
we see all the reports start to become
public I have a really hard time
believing that it's gonna indicate that
he was the only person involved in this
there has to have been some level of the
logistical support or operational
support somewhere in this well one
indication of that Charlie are these
email accounts that he the paddock
apparently maintained ill we learned
about a couple of days ago from which he
sent emails from one to the other
basically address to another person that
person is not named but he was clearly
writing to someone else they were not
just notes to himself what do you make
of that this is very bizarre Tucker and
it's really been bizarre since day one
my understanding after deep research is
that he was emailing himself which kind
of adds to the whole mystery this whole
thing and of course the new development
is married that Lu Dan Lee admitted for
investigators that her prints will be on
the ammo
so I think she's in big trouble right
now and this kind of instant replay to
the pulse nightclub tragedy where the
significant other on that case will be
going to trial in Orlando March first
very interesting to see what's going to
happen would Mary Lou Dan Lee the
girlfriend of mr. Paddick so to the two
questions that Dan asks which are
obviously key questions I would add a
third which is did federal or state
authorities have any knowledge at all of
padic had they had contact with him in
any way were they aware of him before
the shooting do we know anything about
that not to my knowledge no the FBI has
said that they they now know that there
was a lot of ammo in the residence of
the shooter which to me is not very
revealing and not shocking news to
anybody right no especially not in this
case
Sudan do we have any and I don't want
you to speculate or get over your skis
at all because it's too important and we
don't want to muddy it with things we
don't know for certain sure but do you
have any understanding of why it's
taking so long to get basic information
out of this investigation and any
indication as to why it seems to be
conducted in this kind of haphazard
sloppy way um you know I do and I always
appreciate your you you wanting to stick
to what we know I mean I think that
helps and despite the fact that the
government has been I think
unnecessarily cryptic about this which
is fostered a bunch of conspiracy
theories I'm Tucker think about it here
just from unplaned speak there is a very
serious economic and financial incentive
for a lot of the you know potential
secrets in this case to be kept quiet
for a while
and to keep this off the front pages
until the news blows over them I mean
it's very obvious it doesn't take a
conspiracy theorist to figure out you're
the one of the major tourist attractions
in the world Las Vegas is a lot of
outdoor activity on the strip you don't
want on the front page of every paper
from now to perpetuity the fact that you
could be the subject to a subjected to
sniper fire from a building in the Las
Vegas Strip no I know but that's I mean
big companies should not have influence
in criminal investigations I mean that's
like justifying it no no I think you
know what you're you're right that's
clearly what's going
I don't even want to think that that's
true but it clearly is and it's
distressing gentlemen thank you both for
that update